All right,
this is a pretty tricky exercise, so
let's go through all
the steps we need to take.
First we have this need to call
this method somewhere smiley face.
All right thanks, we get the hint.
Next, we see ChromeVox reports
the wrong list size and position.
Okay but we still don't have
enough context to check that.
So let's move on to the next FIXME.
All right, this last one says, need to
ensure focus stays on text box, but
report active list option.
That sounds like a job for
aria-activedescendent, which is designed
to make focus appear to be somewhere
other than the web page focus.
In this case,
we can't use a roving focus technique.
Because if we moved
focus off the text box,
we wouldn't be able to
type into it anymore.
So now we go back to that
subtle hint from earlier,
the setActiveDescendant method
on the combo box prototype.
We can call that here with
that newActive element.
Now if we were to try this out and
we selected Coffee,
it would say one of seven.
And if we selected Cola,
ChromeVox would say five of seven.
What?
If we take a look at the DOM we can see
that we've just hidden the filtered out
list items.
They're still there in the DOM.
Now most screen readers would have no
trouble with this, since they would be
hidden from the accessibility tree, but
ChromeVox works a little differently.
So we're going to use another aria
relationship technique to handle this.
This is where we get back to that
ChromeVox reports the wrong list size
and position, aria-posinset and
aria-setsize are our friends here.
Both of them need to
go on the list items.
So we iterate over the visible list
items, and then we can set aria-posinset
to the item index + 1 since
aria-posinset is a 1 based index.
And aria-setsize to
the number of visibleItems.
Yes, it seems a bit redundant
to set that on every list item,
but this is just how
aria-posinset works.
And if we were to try this out,
we type co and press down,
we would get Coffee one of two,
and Cola two of two.
So we're all set.